so with soaring fireworks the fourth of
july is a time that we honor our freedom
and our patriotism but the sky could be
dark in some places because of fireworks
shortages of course due to
supply chain issues of course but that
is not the case for the souzas who are
often called the first family of
fireworks their explosive displays
arrived just in time and carter evans
has followed the souza family for years
and he shows us how they're ready for an
explosive
that's a good piece of writing there an
explosive show this holiday
[Music]
from the rocket's red glare to bombs
bursting in air
[Music]
for more than a century the sousa family
has been creating magic in the sky
and on the cracked earth deep in the
california desert paul souza builds a
pop-up test site to prepare for the
fourth of july celebrations this little
cup here is the lift charge the fifth
generation show producer is gathering
all the necessary information three two
one fire for his independence day
extravaganzas the way we figure it out
is by stop watching it that burst time
the duration of the effect
and as well as the height of the effect
beautiful purple green combo gold fourth
of july is usually a year in the making
it's a lot of data just to blow a bunch
of stuff up you're right i mean i think
we're all just giddy like teenagers to
do this tonight
the souzas are the firing force behind
some of the world's biggest celebrations
olympic opening ceremonies super bowl
the 75th anniversary of the golden gate
bridge
25 000 explosives specially designed to
withstand san francisco's win created an
unforgettable spectacle
what if it didn't work perfectly exactly
the way you wanted nobody else was going
to know
it still goes it's still going to go
boom and make people happy we're good
paul's dad jim souza is ceo of pyro
spectaculars good to go he's been a
rocket man since the age of 12.
we're into that countdown and we're all
checking controls all right here we are
we're hot and then you get the
goosebumps like i'm getting now into 10
nine eight and then that the first shell
goes up in the air
and yes
that's the magic restrictions to public
events during the kova 19 pandemic hit
fireworks companies hard this year souza
is facing supply chain disruptions from
shipping to trucking
but now he's ready
business is booming it's back everybody
wants to celebrate this is the the sousa
family recipe or cookbook
the cookbook contains their original
formulas for fireworks in the early days
the family made their own
sparks first began flying when manuel de
souza immigrated from portugal in the
early 1900s my great-grandfather was
lighting the fuses by hand with a hand
torch a dynasty was born as each
successive generation joined the family
business but it was dangerous work he
was out to search in the grounds and
found what we call a dud a shell that
came down to the ground didn't explode
and it went off and blew his arm off
their arsenal of explosives is stored in
14 underground bunkers we're walking
through the bunkers we have a great
respect for this product because it is
dangerous and it's life-threatening
with the data from the desert
storyboards are produced then music and
effects are synced to simulations
the results are mesmerizing and
emotional there's moments where i'm
going to
really hit it hard and kind of the
audience going to move back and kind of
be shocked and then we're going to bring
it really low almost bringing the
audience to tears
the souza family pioneered the pyro
musical we've all come to expect on the
4th of july souza says this year the
inspiration behind each independence day
celebration feels especially meaningful
so while people are watching your shows
celebrating on the fourth of july what
do you hope they're thinking i hope
everybody's recognizing our freedom then
if you look in contrast what's going on
the other side of the world in ukraine
they're fighting for their democracy
like we did over 250 years ago they're
fighting for their freedom and we
shouldn't take freedom for granted
[Music]
a year of planning goes into every
30-minute show
but the memories can last a lifetime and
maybe one time with everybody on
different sides of the fences here come
together with family and friends look to
the skies i'll do the rest for you and
celebrate an american tradition
for cbs i'm carter evans
[Music]
i like how paul says you know if it
didn't go off like the way that they
planned you would still be like
yes
well i was thinking you know in this age
of sort of technological entertainment
they got these drone shows and lasers
nothing beats old-school fireworks right
but i always feel like when you see
fireworks it's like
yeah okay they look like fireworks
easy
that's right
no because it's a multi-sensory
experience especially when all the stuff
like falls on you
that was a good show
the kids love it the kids love it i i
this adult loves them uh and has always
loved them the only i want to be here
one year for the new york one i have not
you've never been here never been to new
york i mean the dc one is awesome but
haven't seen the new yorker okay all
right one dad make a date make a date
you're here today well i gotta i'm going
home i'm going on the train